en 1821 le géant des mathématiques Augustin-Louis Cauchy publie son cours d'
analyse de l'école polytechnique
en préface de ce livre remarquable
Cauchy déplore le manque de rigueur des
mathématiques de son temps et
annonce qu'il publie là le premier
ouvrage d'analyse vraiment rigoureux. Sauf que non, j'ai vu une partie du bouquin
de Cauchy
et le niveau de rigueur devant et à
peine celui du lycée en France aujourd'hui
en particulier si vous faites
que fait Cauchy à l'université ou
en prépa vous vous ferais défoncer alors par vos profs
et ce manque de rigueur à un coût énorme.
En effet dans ce cours d'analyse
Cauchy a prouvé
et enseigné
des théorèmes heu.... faux !!!
L'un des théorèmes faux de Cauchy dit qu'une somme infini de fonctions
continues est continues.
Mais Niels Adèle contredit Cauchy en donnant l'exemple d'une étrange
somme infini de sinus qui étaient exactement égales à des dents de scie
or les sinus parfaitement sont continus, les dents de scies
ont clairement
beaucoup de discontinuités
les dents de scie forment donc une
fonction discontinues qui est
pourtant somme infini de fonctions toutes
parfaitement continues
donc Cauchy s'est trompé mais il ne
faut pas trop lui en vouloir
en fait ces sommes infinis de sinus et de cosinus
sont vraiment
très très très déroutantes
ils font partie de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'analyse de foyers laquelle
trouve aujourd'hui une quantité
absolument monstrueuse applications
les mathématiques
l'homme à la crinière et du son en
passant par l'imagerie médicale et la
cosmologie la mécanique quantique
informatique et tout ce que vous voulez
mais pour être honnête avec vous même
si je comprends les outils qui sont
utilisés
pour faire réaliser le foyer
ces sommes 11 ans filles de s'initier le
cosinus
semble pas encore complètement
échappé à m
ma compréhension
commençons par quelques ces trous ce
qui est des séries de fouiller
c'est-à-dire ces sommes sont infinies
des sinus et de cosinus dans la période
divisés une période fondamentale tour
le foyer affirma que toutes les
fonctions de périodiques période de
taux
été somme d'une série de foyers et
là on a envie de rétorquer que cette
année puisque les siens chez costa sur
des fonctions bien et ce qui arrive à
hyères et toulon
alors que
elle conçoit des constructions pépin
biscornus et dénis se compliquer dans
tous les sens mais en disant cela on ne
fait que suivre les traces poussiéreuse
qui plus est
faut il montre comment déterminer
précisément la série es de foyers
d'une fonction
en particulier les coefficients de
foyers soit une année d'études jolie
formule qui peut noter que le produit
d'une fonction par le dossier ne
soulevons cosinus si vous ne comprenez
pas c'est fort mais ce n'est pas grave
ce que je veux souligner l'article des
compositions de fouiller correspond à
une équation d'une simplicité
remarquable sauf que contrairement à ce
que disait foyer toutes les fonctions
périodique ne peuvent pas en fait
être décomposé personne et si c'est
possible
il aura fallu tout un siècle pour que
l'on comprenne mieux qu'hier les
fonctionnalités des composants avancés
de foyers
en 1907
price épicière pourront troquer les
fonctions que les séries de foyers
décrié son exacte dont celle dite de
castries intégral toutes ces fonctions
son intérieur égal à leur série de
foyers
en plus de faire super gaffe à ce que
je veux dire
quand on dit qu'une seule
le film qui signifie que les sinistrés
et du talent
à une autre fonction
dans l'épisode 2 e vous avez dit qu'une
femme un film de londres était
également une certaine quantité
si les sommes partielles se rapprocher
de la quantité en question temps très
cassant par cette affaire
étonnamment étrange
ecstasy proche
que la fonction tentation censé se
rapprochait
c'est ce que l'on appelle l'effet
d'éviction des effets de bord
qui avait totalement échappé aux
mathématiciens du 19e siècle sur la
figure l écran d une courbe bleue qui
est la fonction turbo chercherait-elle
plus avec une série de foyers ici c'est
une fonction un escalier
les courbes rousseau l'essonne partiel
successives de l'essai de foyers qui
sont donc censés se rapprocher de la
courbe bleue et quand on les regarde de
plus près on voit qu'au niveau des dix
plus que limité et cette obstination de
foyers ont plutôt tendance à
s'éloigner du coup le but
or pour certaines applications notamment
physiquement il ne faut pas que
l'approximation de foyers privés d
amplitude énorme
ceci peut être vraiment problématique
en termes mathématiques on dit que la
série de foyers de convergex le pas
selon la norme un fini
mais à l'inversé un sens précis selon
lesquelles
la cci de pau et d'une fonction mettre
véritablement il galère
à la fonction elle même pour ceux qui
connaissent et c'est au sens de la norme
dite
elles devront ils viennent
je ne vais pas entrer dans les détails
mais il faut comprendre que l'égalité
entre eux une fonction et sa série de
foyers des ports fortement du sens que
l'on donne
aussi mérité de gagner
et en particulier au sens que l'on donne
proximité l'étude rigoureuse de tout
ça à partir de ce qu'on appelle
l'analyste optionnelle
c'est super difficile
mais ça peut être super critique pour
certaines applications
paf vous voyez que c'est le foyer s'est
déjà c'est super compliqué
et pourtant c'est ultra respectifs
puisqu'on a ajouté l'agent uniquement
des salles de s'immiscer de cosinus
dans la période difficile une certaine
période complémentaire
que se passe-t-il alors
si j'ajoute
tous les clichés tous les cosmétiques
de toutes les périodes imaginaire
je pense
tetris
ultra déroutant
in addition de toutes les périodes de
deux auteurs se faire à l'aide d'une
sorte de soucoupe soutenu mon style
que l'on appelle m des grains
dans le cas de l'église de fouiller il
s'agit des clubs plus huppés neuf
communes sous un train continuum qui
signifie de cosinus
push l'accident ne se serait possible il
multiplie les précautions d l'activité
cette semaine poutine des soucis de
cosmétiques pour bébés
comme ce que je vais attaquer
l'intégrale de fouilles éreinté gras
des faux et c'est quelque chose de
superviseurs
en fait c'est à déplorer mais plus
surprenant que je connais à des
mathématiques elle a conclu sur
stupéfiante de foyers au sujet de ces
intégrales
qui a été formalisée roubaix
rigoureusement harper en forêt
en 1910 voici ce que disent les
théorèmes époustouflant
toutefois ils sont tous ensuite nous
avons eu 8 00 m tigane
nous sommes continuellement culture
des sinus et de cosigner
plus précisément un stade de rennes
spycher plancherel montre qu il suffit
que le couple soit de café intégrables
pour qu'elle soit ainsi
il gagne
classement intégral du courrier
qui plus est m
comme dans le cas des séries de
fouilles
les coefficients un décret qui est
privilégiée l'intégrale de pluie
peut-être déterminer l'aide publique
qui ne sont autres que des intégrales
de fouiller elles-mêmes
ces coefficients un détective privé
grec son intérieur en fait d'une
fonction
qui sont des sortes de représentation
d'autres fonctions f
dès que l'on appelle le public
transformée de fourier de l'ue
à l'instar de
ces coefficients sont donc
nous aussi
helsinki plus possible
les états sont super technique mais le
message final absolument stupéfiant
thoune fonction qui comme suffisamment
vite vers zéro à l'infini
c'est une somme infini de fonction qui
elle ne tente jamais vers zéro à
l'infini
en fait ces fonctions même qui
composent la fonction d'origine qui tend
vers zéro
ces fonctions qui sont les sinus et
cosinus
paz être écrite comme des salles
insigne en continu
mais si c est possible
eh oui elle ne tente pas vers zéro à
l'infini
alors on pourrait croire que tout ce que
raconte la cfdt une qualité
qui n'intéresse que des matheux et
pourtant tout ceci se trouve aucunement
la théorie la plus fondamentales de la
physique de journée la mécanique
quantique
dans cette théorie une particule est
forcément une superposition de vitesse
et de position à tout instant
la superposition de position à ce qu'on
appelle la fonction d'onde c'est quelque
chose qui varient dans l'espace et en
gros les endroits où la fonction de
prendre les grandes valeurs dans
l'espace ce sont les endroits aucune
particule plus de présence legaret a
transformé de la fonction d'onde d'une
particule
elsa superpositions de vitesse
renvoi vers cet excès en ville de sion
cette annonce et cet autre excellente
vidéo délocalisation universe pour en
savoir plus ce que l'analyse de faux et
montrent que plus de particuliers
localiser plus ça veut dire que sa
présence à l'infini et très
rapidement très proche de zéro
et ça ça veut dire qu'elle doit être
une somme de beaucoup d'essais c'est
donc aussi ce que chacun des services
écosystémiques infiniment est allé
dans l'espace
pour faire un truc lequel et il faut
vraiment elle était vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup autrement dit la
transformée de fourier de la fonction
dont ceux qui répertorie en gros tous
les cinéphiles que signifie contribue
à former la fonction d'onde
cette transformer le foyer va forcément
être très étalée il fait quoi ce
point beaucoup de sièges et de cosinus
et ça ça revient à dire qu'une autre
particule
d'être composée de bons coups
de vitesse différentes
à l'inversé signe particulier composé
de plus de vitesse
ça veut dire
que sa fonction d'onde
est une superposition de planet sushi de
cosinus
c'est cette affaire ressemble à un gros
travail même s'il est possible qu'il
soit très étalées à travers l'espace
ce nom vous parle là
c'est du principe d'incertitude
demeurent à l'avant-garde même si moi
personnellement je le déteste c'est
terminé je préfère appeler ça
le principe d'étalement
les agenais
car au fond ce que dit ce principe c'est
une partie qui ne peut pas être à la
fois une superposition de très peu de
positions
et de très peu de vitesse
soit son étalement dans l'espace assez
grand soit c'est son étalement en
vitesse
si le secteur
en conclusion j'aimerais bien capituler
un peu cette histoire assez folle
de l'analyse de fous rires début du
17ème siècle c'est avant tout une
source de bizarreries mathématiques
qui permettait de construire des objets
mystérieux assez incompréhensible
et tout ça ça me motive énormément
de recherches pour plus de rigueur
mathématique
qui tout au long du disque ème siècle
aura amené à l'analyse moderne et tout
ça ça a préparé le terrain pour
cause 20e siècle
on est encore en forme
une compréhension plus poussée
de ces bizarreries mathématiques et
c'est à ce moment-là
que les mathématiques
enfin prête
à être utilisé pour développer une
nouvelle théorie révolutionnaire de la
physique
la mécanique quantique
que de chemin parcouru
je vous le promets
on est loin d'avoir fait le plein
mais à la fin on a parlé des nombreux
stands et d'autres anciennes et vous
avez été nombreux à ne signer que je
n'avais pas tout compris
à la vidéo précédente première
chose à dire ce n'est pas tout compris
c'est parfaitement normal la plupart des
pays d origine sont très difficiles à
comprendre pour le liseur et ça c'est
tout à fait normal de ne pas avoir
compris
il ne bute s'est amusé tout compris et
produire un visionnage barça peut
surprendre certains d'entre vous mais je
pense qu'en fait c'est très important
de laisser en suspens certaines choses
de de comprendre comment t'as tout
compris
il dit avoir surtout quelque chose que
l'on peut méditer chez soi après la
vidéo c'est vraiment il ne
décrocherait ce que vous continuiez à
réfléchir après avoir vu la vidéo
public pour cela elle le mieux à mon
sens bien
c'était dur psychologiquement
mais il faut qu'on se connaissait dans
le monde comprendront pas se compliquer
les choses dans un communiqué et c'est
pour ça que
si vous ne comprenez pas tout mais mes
idéaux
la semaine après six années j'espère
surtout que le pagne qui est comparable
non vous n'avez pas tout compris
l'utilisation très normal de ne pas
avoir tout compris
il n'y a pas d'intermédiaire près de
deux secondes par coup je vais m'excuser
pour la vidéo précédente parce que je
pense que certains passages
il n'avait pas lieu d'être dans la
vidéo parce qu'ils étaient trop
compliqué parce que sur les organes
sociaux et c'est un petit peu emporter
parce que contrairement à l'egypte
ainsi on sait d'ores et déjà fait des
vidéos cela dit j depuis dix ans la
société
ces superbes vidéos qui montrent les
exemples du coup je me suis dit
j'ai essayé déjà sur internet diab a
répété ce qu'il avait dit et
répété il faut y aller un petit peu
plus loin j'ai tendance à s'opposer aux
épices déjà d'ici à vendredi c'est
peut-être une erreur de ma part
né par les voix lisible et voir cette
vidéo ça nous permet de bien mieux
comprendre la vidéo suite
et puis surtout ça super confiant et on
trouve aussi des trucs les plus en verve
lors d'une épidémie cannes ce sont 14
heures 20 l'euro gmt matthieu morando
me pose des questions sur les autres
opérations qui emploie 40% des trucages
unités après avoir poussé le disque
il ya eu nombre de cardinaux city
peuvent être évitées multiplier sur
le post fr des exportations des
cardinaux mais en fait état d'une
hausse est assez drôle ces derniers
jours
des calculs arithmétiques notamment
l'édition et la même chose que la
médication style fait un pli carrière
plus votre argent cardinal
c'est également la première fini
cardinale fois le deuxième acte fini le
cardinal il est en fait ça va être
tout simplement le plus grand des deux
infinis donc si l'arithmétique décalé
aux centrifugeuses est vraiment bourré
elle détient désormais au service de
la première place jeudi à paris dans
le cadre de cette cession à genoux et
avait parlé d'une opération assez
étrange qui a été fait
parce que les caisses du club les
bâtiments de se connecter sur heineken
de nombreux cambodgiens
ici on fait par exemple aux médias
comédien
il exacerbe la chancelière qui ont fait
au méga fête flèche médias
dans notre avenir prometteur je connais
bien il faut y remédier à la situation
et ça ça va être
promet d'être soumis à la torture
c'est très bien
et sur la nécessité de 7 0
maintenant qu'est-ce que notre sortie
renégats fesf ph
ph médias
un cancer c'est sainté qui est
certainement très très très très
très grand je suis même pas sûr qu'on
puisse les cures thermales des
pyrénées mais on peut même aller plus
loin comme le propose à matthieu
morando et définir pour les gars
la fff et acheter
l'équipe au méga flèche
et avec un méga obou
et là on maintient un truc est vraiment
archimica gigantesque mais ce sera
encore plus petit que connaît guère
puisque sion définir les flèches du
club présents des mots comme ça ça
restera un ordinariat d'innombrables
monstres apprécié
un vote défavorable d je sais à quel
point elle est à la recherche en santé
du théorème déléguée syndicale on
retrouve la consistance d'un crédit de
bnp sur ses sites entre son pays et le
deuxième plus haut la main
la complétude de d2 qui dit que
l'arithmétique de guerre ne peut pas
prouver sa propre consistance en fait il
a étudié deux pianos elle ne peut pas
approuvés la défense antimissile
américaine 0 qu'utilise quais de seine
pour prouver
la consistance de l'arithmétique de
gagner du coup on sort du cadre de bon
augure à la complétude
de désabusement train de parler
cité de l'agouti de piano avec une
théorie qui est de l'extérieur de la
ville de kano selon cette étude menée
par le médiatique ceci étant dit et il
ya beaucoup de jours entraînant en
éveil jdd samedi
qui a pas mal le critiquer a dit le
plein des quais de seine en disant
qu'elle utilise une récurrence qui est
plus forte que l'arithmétique de piano
pourquoi
trouvez-moi son garde du corps est un
petit peu débile comme raisonnement en
fait c'est pas tout à fait des visayas
très clairement plus calme le terrain
de gamme scène puisque la critique
primitive récursif plus haut de cette
récurrence trains supprimés jusqu'à
10h00 ne permettent pas de construire la
ville de perth now n'intégrait pas
toutes agglutinées place
elle implique il vise uniquement à la
consistance des règles équitables
c'était quelque chose de très subtil
ce qui faisait dire que carragher de
cette baisse a été suffisant pour
résister mieux qu'on puisse faire
pourquoi elles sont confiants pour la
consistance
il a été décidé de bien d'autres en
parlera beaucoup plus en détail tout
ça quand on parlera la cuisine de
l'auberge
il a ensuite dû terrain vague
mais bien sûr tout ça ça pose la
question de l'existence à l'origine des
ordinands que ce sont les questions que
pose
l'egypte d et mme bachelot
en arrière la réponse de base est
située au bout de se redéfinir les
théories mathématiques dans laquelle
ces ordinateurs il existe huit musées
d'histoire a du coup dans un monde
mathématiques par exemple on sait bien
que c'est plus tard par la crise des
dettes dans cette série mais avec la
fpp % michel en main et à l'instar de
d'autres parmi vous dans les
commentaires sans le dire que ceux-ci
n'existent que dans un monde aux
mathématiques et qu'il faut aller dans
son sens at-elle dit pour le croire
c'est peut-être parce que c'est une
question philosophique à partir de ce
moment-là le
il convient donc de se battre pour la
grèce
savoir si il existe vraiment ces ordures
dans la rue
ce que je veux dire
c'est le coeur pour ne pas être trop
pour contenir retraités les distances
de
les objets
dans le monde réel je pense que la
physique du 20e siècle nous sommes nous
a vraiment montré que le monde
il est bien plus compliqué bien plus
étrange bien plus concret puisque ce
qu'on pourrait croire naïvement donc
soyons vraiment prudent quand on parle
du monde réel pour installer
personne ne pensait que l'assuré ces
données qui viennent ça qui est
vraiment montréal et avant la finale
personne ne pensait
les sérigraphies divergentes
et avoir un quelconque utilité
pour étudier
montréal est en fait il se trouve qu'il
est très sensible à ritchie
d'où peut-être laissé ça en dit long
seront un jour très utile
pour étudier et physique
j'espère que vous avez laissé les
paysannes
tout ce qu'on va faire un truc trop
forte
d'ici son retour dans le grand hall
pendant les cours de piano et de toute
liberté
autre chose on attend on ne pas attendre
le 10 mai
sur internet ce sera le cas c'est
pourquoi nous avons fait des progrès
dans certains certes le faire les
factures on devrait permettre à toutes
vos questions
dans les commentaires ou sur twitter en
refusant de jeter les gants cependant le
prix puis yves christen jeudi
pour essayer de sortir cette semaine
de la fed cup
si vous avez aimé cette date après
laquelle commentaire
partagé par sa faisabilité quinze
épisodes personne qui perd pas en
danger j'espère que vous faire j'en
profite nick clegg avec la crise un
match épique gp certaines clauses
techniques applicables quelque part cela
je suis plus fier
les élèves
ma